real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below
let's start today looking at some of the
most important and key races coming up
now as we are just about eight weeks
away
from the 2022 midterm elections now
we've looked generally at how things are
shaping up meaning in general
democrats have a likely shot at holding
the senate and it is most likely that
republicans are going to take the house
of representatives but to really
understand kind of the texture of what's
going on
we have to go beyond just the top line
numbers and really look at some specific
races and unfortunately while there is
quite a bit of good news if you look at
the specific races some of the specific
races that we've been covering
there is
i mean i can't really call it anything
other than extraordinarily disturbing
polling data
showing that this is a really messed up
country i mean there there's sometimes
you know we want to come up with the
most sophisticated and detailed and
nuanced way of looking at a situation in
the in the political world but
it's just
things are really screwed up because of
some really messed up people and let's
start with sort of like what's okay and
then we'll get into what's not looking
quite so good so all right in
pennsylvania in the senate there's this
very important race uh television dr
mehmet oz versus the democratic
lieutenant governor john fetterman
fetterman is extraordinarily smart
uh extraordinarily qualified
has logical consistent positions on
issues
and is a great candidate on the other
hand you have television dr mehmet oz
who has taken every side of all issues
masks
of vaccines um quack cures
abortion whatever
um isn't even really from pennsylvania
although you know it's for pennsylvania
voters to decide whether that's
something that they care about if it's i
mean listen there would be candidates
that are so good that if they moved to
some new state on day one and on day two
said i'm running i would vote for them
so it's up to pennsylvanians to decide
whether they care about the that
um and is just completely unqualified
and the good news is that on average
fetterman is leading polls by six and a
half as you can see here
the bad news is that fetterman's only
leading by six and a half so like when
we look at this is this good or is this
bad well it would be worse if oz was
leading
but this should be a 30-point blowout a
40-point blowout if the world made sense
another example also in pennsylvania
this one's really important governor's
race doug mastriano
a um big lie proponent
an attendee of january 6th a guy who we
know if he is governor in 2024
and a democrat wins pennsylvania
masteriano will try to steal the
pennsylvania electoral votes for the
republican disaster absolute and total
disaster
doug i'm sorry josh shapiro is winning
but only by six
by all reasonable standards the world
looks at this race and says wait a
second
you've got a completely uncontroversial
standard
reasonable
law supporting due process supporting
pro-law and order democrat
and you've got masteriano who just got
caught wearing a confederate uniform and
shapiro's only up six what is wrong with
americans and that is the correct
reaction why is he only winning by six
look at florida
um in florida we've got incumbent
republican senator marco rubio being
challenged by democratic congresswoman
val demings rubio is
just one of the
he's one of the shakiest senators for
sure
um and the one poll we have recently is
from august if you go before that you
have to go all the way back to february
so the one recent poll has val demings
up four
that's good
but rubio is a humiliation to the senate
he should be getting crushed and we have
only an inkling that maybe demings has a
shot that's really disturbing
and then we have the arizona senate uh
blake masters versus mark kelly mark
kelly the democrat incumbent
smart guy
relatively progressive guy not the most
progressive uh former astronaut
a thinker in in many ways
and blake masters is just a cartoonish
clown
and somehow kelly is only up by six so
it's good i mean listen it's good that
kelly is winning but only by six that's
really concerning now then we get into
the absolutely cuckoo for coco puff
stuff take a look at some of these
numbers in the georgia senate you have
the thoughtful
empathetic intelligent incumbent
democratic senator rafael warnock
being challenged by the republican
candidate former football player
herschel walker who cannot speak
he cannot speak he cannot formulate a
coherent opinion on any issue
and in the average of recent polls
warnock is leading by only one
by only one folks walker cannot speak
and he cannot think
and raphael warnock is winning by only
one that is a georgia dystopia
also in georgia you have this
loony republican governor brian kemp
the incumbent being challenged by stacey
abrams abrams is brilliant abrams has
done more for voting expansion in
georgia over the last decade than anyone
i can think of
and kemp is winning by an average of
five points there the world is backwards
truly backwards a couple others that are
just really scary uh or one more in
texas you've got the incumbent governor
greg abbott who has overseen a radical
restriction of access to abortion
services family planning he's involved
in this
absolutely loony isolation of the texas
power grid and he supports it and he
defends it and he loves it
and then he is being challenged by beto
o'rourke
who i like quite a bit not the most
progressive but
very strong on guns very strong on
women's rights and abbott is leading by
an average
of about seven points
consider that republicans are truly
offering
nothing right now nothing republicans
offer
obstructionism and
we will own the libs and anger the lives
they're not even offering bad policy
they're offering no policy and yet in
some of these places the electorate the
constituents are so weaponized by
disinformation they've fallen for
whatever local version of
maga
uh
that that is prevalent
and many of them are going to win so
these numbers these data as some like to
say
are as reflective
of the sad state of american politics as
they are of this just sort of reality
that usually when one party takes the
white house in the next midterm that
party doesn't do well like that's a
general structural thing
fine
but some of these numbers i mean warnock
versus walker
just the humiliation are reflective of
the the weaponization
of almost it's like a pride
in not being about anything other than
just angering the left and that's
actually sort of working for some of
them so we'll continue looking at all
these numbers later in the week i'll
give you updated numbers on how is the
house looking how is the senate looking
and we will go from there
many people wrote in to me saying david
did you see
the assassination attempt of the
argentinian vice president christina
kirschner which was caught on video
david you're argentinian
please tell us what you think about this
issue
well i have to tell you and this is
going to anger a lot of people including
even some people in my friends and
family
uh the entire thing stinks to high
heaven that's my honest view so let me
tell you what allegedly happened and
then we're going to kind of dig into it
in more detail
bbc news reports christina kirschner
gunned jams
during bid to kill
argentina vice president
argentina's vice president has narrowly
avoided assassination after a gunman's
weapon jammed as he aimed at her footage
shows the moment that christina found
herself face to face with the loaded
weapon
the former president was outside her
home surrounded by a mob of supporters
who back her in her fight against
corruption charges police said the
gunman identified as a 35 year old
brazilian man had been taken into
custody they're trying to establish
motive the president alberto fernandez
revealed the gun was loaded with five
bullets but failed to fire when
triggered and indeed this was caught on
video
and you see this
it really is incredible video where you
see christina walking around
and all of a sudden a handgun is right
in her face
and then she looks christina looks down
at the floor and it's not clear she
knows what happened and then all of
these security people of which she has
dozens and dozens around her all the
time
run over and then this guy is taken into
custody i have to be really really
honest with you guys to me this stinks
to high heaven and i know many people
don't necessarily follow argentinian
politics and what's going on there
christina
is
a
criminally corrupt individual and there
are major charges against her there's a
corruption trial where a prosecutor is
seeking a 12-year sentence against her
and a lifelong ban from the office uh
from from running from holding public
office she says she's the victim of
political pers persecution prosecution
both terms kind of apply here
and
it is really not looking good for her
now you might remember there was another
prosecutor alberto niesman
who also was moving forward very very
strongly against her with corruption and
other charges and just before
he was going to be presenting evidence
in a court of law
he was found dead of a supposed suicide
now having studied that issue
seriously for many years
i don't believe that niecemann killed
himself it doesn't make any sense when
you understand the full scope of the
story and so now you have another
prosecutor who is bringing serious
charges serious evidence the other day
the president of argentina said i hope
this guy doesn't also kill himself in a
completely dystopian almost putin-like
statement
and then now all of a sudden
despite the fact that christina has
dozens of security people
some
poor brazilian guy
is able to go right up to her
and point a gun right at her head and
there were five bullets in the gun and
oops the gun jammed and christina's
absolutely fine and all of a sudden all
of the attention is on this rather than
the very serious crimes of which
christina is accused so call me
skeptical yes call me skeptical now
there are people and and by the way i
know people will write in our my
argentinian viewers will say
ludo
you're a mockery guy you're a right
winger no no no no no i think that
mauricio macri
basically argentinian trump
uh was also horrible and did a few good
things did a few good things okay but
not a guy that i supported
the
the the context here is very different
just because i think christina's corrupt
doesn't mean i'm a right winger doesn't
mean i like mockery or whatever
um but to it it all absolutely stinks to
me
so oh and but what i was getting to was
many of the people
who love christina are reacting to
people saying what i'm saying by saying
oh you sick supporter of violence you
want her assassinated
no
no
i don't want anybody assassinated i want
everybody alive and well
and able to face whatever charges are
brought against them in the judicial
system okay so no i'm not advocating for
anyone's assassination so that's my view
on this and to the extent that people in
the audience might be following it
um let me know what you think
real quick
september 19th we are doing it's 9 19
and we are doing a 19 themed membership
special
it's too good to even reveal what it is
so if you've been thinking oh i don't
know maybe i'll get the membership maybe
i'll get access to that bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad yeah if you've
been thinking about that and you've been
waiting for the right opportunity i
suggest the right opportunity is
september 19th where we will be emailing
everybody on our mailing list about this
great membership special if you want to
be notified
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is jayatal
jaital is a stellar melodic dance music
duo in one of the uk's most exciting
electronic acts
jayatal have made their name through
legendary live shows that incorporate
drums guitar electronics taking them on
tours across europe they've appeared on
bbc their newest release called
connected will knock you off your feet
written and recorded entirely remotely
during covid my favorite track from the
album is the one you're hearing right
now called it's coming round again
[Music]
probably because i'm a drummer but i
love acoustic drums accompanied by a bed
of electronic layers and the track
really gets the drums going in all of
their music even something as simple as
the synth bass sounds like it was
carefully adjusted for hours to hit your
ear just the right way these guys will
take you on a journey and jayatal are
big fans of the david pakman show if you
like unusual but deeply gratifying
electronica check out jayatal on their
new release connected wherever you
stream or buy music they're on youtube
and social media you can book them for a
show and you can find them using the
link below
all right this is going to be a segment
of contrasts we are going to really take
a tour through the full miliew of the
american political culture we're going
to start with president joe biden we're
then going to move to failed former
president donald trump and then we're
going to hear from some current
supporters of the failed former
president donald trump and i think you
will see that this will really put on
display the full panoply of what is
going on in american politics right now
now i want to start with joe biden and i
have to tell you
i
love the new joe biden it doesn't mean i
agree with him on all policy and there's
so many things i wish he would do that
he hasn't done but he has done many
things in the last three months but what
i really love about the new joe biden
is he is doing what gavin newsom said
has to happen
we can't just be
meek on the left
we have to come out swinging because
we're right on the issues
and we have the moral high ground these
are deeply delusional dangerous
unthinking people on the right
and gavin newsom said democrats have to
point that out and increasingly biden is
doing it okay
a heckler a biden spoke in milwaukee
wisconsin over the weekend and a heckler
flipped out and started screaming as
often happens
and biden actually says no no no let him
go by the way if it were at a trump
rally uh
well we'll talk about that in a moment
but then biden says listen le he
everybody's entitled to be an idiot and
it's not i mean it from the bottom of my
heart
as i said last week
we remain in the battle
for the soul of america
by the way
all right god love you
let him go
let him go
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no don't
let him go
remember when this happened at a trump
rally trump would go get him the hell
out of here look everybody's entitled to
be an idiot
no no everybody's there okay
look
so anyway yeah i mean at a trump rally
the heckler would be beaten to a pulp
um and then trump would uh
say that he will pay the attackers legal
bills and then wouldn't actually pay
them he would offer to pay we know trump
doesn't really pay legal bills but he
would offer to do that
also during the speech biden refers to
the maga people as the trumpets which i
think is the perfect combination of
condescending and emasculating
but all kids aside
we we did fine no no complaints we did
fine
but here's the point
the biggest contrast
from what mega republicans the extreme
right the the
the the trump is
yeah
i kind of like trumpies better than
trumpists because sometimes when i say
trumpists people hear trumpets and
that's not what i'm saying
um and then lastly here's a uh a new
little bonus from joe biden making fun
of himself for being old
and as i said i just signed in the law
historic inflation reduction act
it wasn't
easy to take on big drug companies but
we did
i've been fighting them since i got in
congress 180 years ago
anyway listen i
i like this this is what newsome was
talking about
it can't be only this it has to be
paired with legislative accomplishments
and a strong economy and we have both of
those things right now but this is what
gavin newsom was talking about i just
didn't necessarily expect it to come
from the nearly 80 year old joe biden
but i welcome it i just ask
where on earth has this joe biden been
for roughly the last year and a half so
that was biden over the weekend
now to contrast it let's go to trump
very differently than joe biden's
weekend
donald trump did a rally in pennsylvania
ostensibly to promote
john fetterman's opponent mehmet oz
and josh shapiro's opponent
doug mastriano ostensibly i say because
every trump rally is actually about
himself and donald trump coming out and
says the current president of the united
states right joe biden
is the enemy of the state he used to say
the media was the enemy of the people
now he says the president is the enemy
of the state as you know this week
joe biden came to
philadelphia pennsylvania to give the
most vicious hateful and divisive speech
ever delivered by an american president
other than every trump speech i guess
vilifying 75 million citizens plus
another probably 75 to 150.
trump thinks there might be 225 million
trumpists in the united states
but he's never been good at counting
that we know be accurate about it
as threats to democracy and as
enemies of the state you're all enemies
of the state
he's an enemy of the state you want to
know the truth
so there it is a former president
calling the current president an enemy
of the state
and the dystopian authoritarianism
didn't stop there
uh trump also went on to say without any
evidence that john fetterman the guy
running against memet oz
is taking all sorts of hard drugs
there's no evidence of that
fetterman supports taxpayer-funded drug
dens
and the complete decriminalization
of illegal drugs
including
heroin
cocaine
crystal meth
and ultra lethal fentanyl and by the way
he takes them himself
it's completely out of nowhere
there's no evidence i've seen
that fetterman
uh is thinking i mean it's crazy
and part of this is this new almost
dictatorial authoritarian thing that
trump is doing which is calling for the
death penalty for drug dealers
they kill 500 people during a lifetime
and i think it's much worse than that i
think that's only what we hear about
it would stop it i i if you didn't get
it down 75 80 90 from day one i'd be
surprised
and these committees that they set up
it's laughable it's a horrible thing we
would solve that problem so fast and i'm
calling on republicans and democrats
immediately to institute to get to
washington and institute the death
penalty for drug dealers you will no
longer have
a problem
and the crowd cheers which is maybe the
scariest part i mean listen we know
trump loves dictators
and this
this is straight out of the duterte
playbook this is straight
sort of out of the she playbook this is
what dictatorial authoritarian autocrats
do and trump now openly saying kill the
drug dealers and by the way when trump
was in power he let numerous drug
dealers out of prison he pardoned a
former drug trafficker he pardoned 13
drug dealers during his last month in
office so it's also total and complete
hypocrisy now
here's the point at which trump's
cognitive state was questioned
trump said that facebook founder mark
zuckerberg
last week visited trump at the white
house and kissed his ass last week you
remember in the campaign i used to say
if these people get in we're going to
end up with venezuela on steroids i said
it many many times i never thought it
was much of a possibility but i never
knew people could cheat like that not
like that
last week
weirdo
is a weirdo mark zuckerberg came to the
white house kissed my ass what the hell
is he talking about
and the audience finds it completely
last week zuckerberg kissed your ass at
the white house
kiss my sure i've looked after them
sir i'd love to have dinner i'd love to
bring my lovely wife all right what a
biz i mean something is very wrong
something very serious is going on if
trump thinks that he met with zuckerberg
it all honestly it reminds me of what
this is sad
but later in fred trump's life when he
was suffering very seriously cognitively
um
he sort of worked in like a fake office
it was like the truman show remember the
great jim carrey movie where jim carrey
thought he was living a normal life but
it was all stage managed for him
um
they would like put papers on fred
trump's desk and they would have a phone
where
someone pretending to be i mean like i
guess it was his secretary but it they
weren't really doing any work
he would speak to his secretary on the
phone
it almost is like is that what's going
on with trump does trump think hey
a guy with a fake curly hair wig this is
mark zuckerberg sir he's here to meet
with you oh mr mr president um we want
to go to dinner
is it possible that there's like a
truman show type thing going on with
trump or has trump just have no idea
what's going on it's very very strange
and then in this next clip this is
really interesting
in this clip you can really just feel
the jealousy and envy
dripping off of trump about barack obama
president got anywhere near
i think we got like 10 million more
votes than obama got obama you know
obama
so popular
he's so popular they say he's so
handsome oh obama's so happy
he's such a great speaker what does he
say
he says nothing so basically trump is
very jealous of barack obama because
obama's popular and more handsome than
trump and a better speaker than trump i
mean that's as childish as this is
that's what he's saying and then this is
beyond belief
trump criticizes fetterman
as being spoiled
for living off of family money this is
beyond parody if you know trump's
background axes
he is a spoiled and entitled
socialist loser who leeched off his
parents money you know he lives on the
parent's money
until taxes
he is a spoiled yeah and of course
donald trump
has basically his entire fortune because
of his father really really wild stuff
i was going to play the clip of the
completely unvarnished transphobia that
is now a regular part of these rallies
it's the exact same three stories trump
always tells you know the weightlifting
stuff
and the swimmer and that teachers
shouldn't be allowed to teach
transgender so i'm just gonna skip it
but a real tale of contrasts the biden
speech over the weekend and the trump
speech let's now look at some of the
people that went to the trump rally
i continue to insist
that the maga cultists the trumpies
as joe biden called them
are yes
they are indoctrinated cultists but they
are dangerous as well here's just a
little bit of a sampling from the
pennsylvania rally here are mag
occultists chanting trump one
it's hard
it's hard to get through all this steve
i just
yeah uh just because you say something
over and over and over and over and over
and over again for two years
doesn't make it true
here's a guy who wants trump back i
think what this guy is saying is that
his parents would abuse him meaning this
guy's parents abused this guy
and thus
trump is similar and is good what they
say about donald trump they say that
he's mean and everything well you know
what when you're growing up it was your
father who kicked you your mother kicked
you in the ass to keep you on a
straightened hour and that's what he
does
i went on the leader i don't want a lamb
that's right a leader a leader not a
lamb we know yeah so that's really more
sad than anything else to be perfectly
honest here's one guy who just might be
drunk which is certainly no crime but if
you think it's tough to defend trump
while sober it's a lost cause when drunk
don't even try you should have folks all
the things the economy is it's
ridiculous and the way
these other people they want to change
the whole country they are changing it
they're ruining it what they're doing
donald gionee boy that can straighten it
out i'll tell you that um yeah
so there is a gentleman expressing his
well-thought-out opinion here's a woman
who is wearing a trump one shirt that's
now a mainstay at the rallies
i believe that this woman says obama and
hillary should be in jail obama i want
to mark
and they stop it still you know stuff is
new
she wants them to stop the steal right
away
we know who won and that's a joke one
but they they they're very cheating and
now why we do that why every i know come
for obama well if i know come for about
one like clinton
right why didn't the fbi come from for
obama and and hillary i think she's
asking which we know the answers to that
because there was nothing to come after
them for
some of the messaging terms why they do
that you know
yeah i hope to back and we never get up
thank you so much yep so uh that was you
know another one of these delusional
declarations
here's a guy who was he's he was at the
rally he was also in washington dc on
january 6th and he says he was even
investigated by the fbi we were going to
come back the first saturday of every
month and give that they gave us not my
present for four years you're gonna say
not my president and have these speeches
every month like clockwork what an
embarrassment that would be so the
democrats had to pull the security and
let a riot happen and let somebody get
die
so they could stop these rallies so they
could say see trump rallies are
dangerous people get killed you know who
gets killed we get killed
uh but also on top of that
the fbi when they came to my house they
wanted to know if i was plotting on
overthrowing the government
now what am i supposed to answer then oh
yeah i am actually yeah
all right so very common thing lots of
trump rallies have january 6 attendees
um
one other clip for you and this is more
sad than anything else here's a woman
who says she camped out for five days at
the trump rally to get the best seats i
mean this is this is sick
we've been here me and mike bowman's
been here since tuesday night tuesday
night you guys tuesday night today is
saturday that's tuesday wednesday
thursday friday five days early to see
president trump wow on site
we've had a wonderful time and we can't
wait to see the president and show him
how much we when they say this
i i know that you refer to former
president still as mr president
but the way in which these people just
talk about we want to see the president
it really seems they think he's still
the president supporting
incredible mike how has the past five
nights been for you camping right here
to make sure that you get the front row
spot i mean what continues to encourage
you to very sick people it isn't put
that much effort and money into this
donald trump i mean
we need him back and i'll do anything
you know to help the support for him
thank you so much and we've got some all
right and just an absolutely electric uh
speaker as you can see
imagine being this delusional so we have
a real sickness in this country and as
i've said before i don't know
how we educate ourselves out of this
stuff
i really don't
but i'm interested in hearing your
thoughts on how we do it
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the media civil war is now getting
really really interesting as donald
trump appears to have completely turned
on fox news and is now offering to help
cnn
crush fox by becoming conservative which
i know this is crazy
it sort of seems cnn might be doing
under new leadership so let's like back
it up a few steps and then we're going
to go through this first and foremost
there has been a growing
tension i guess we would call it between
mega trump world
and fox news
because there have been little hints
that fox news is interested in making
the jump away from trump now if you
actually sit and watch fox fox and
friends or whatever shows hannity
tucker
they're still very generally speaking
deferential to trump but i do agree
that fox news has its finger to the wind
and to some degree they want a plan
in case trump is not the republican
nominee in 2024
fox was not big on trump at the
beginning of the 2016 primary and
maybe they want to keep their options
open that is absolutely true
but trump and other hardcore trumpists
have started to say
fox has gone woke
fox has abandoned magga and now you've
got to go to whether it's newsmax or oan
or who the hell knows where if you
really want the trump stuff
so
the other
part of this story is that cnn now under
new leadership
reportedly wants to go more in the
direction of showing both sides or
whatever now sadly cnn seems to be
falling a bit into this kind of
enlightened centrism idea of we must
give both sides on everything well
weather report says it's raining you
look out the window and it is raining
but we need to give the side that says
it's a sunny day that's idiotic and
that's the problem that a lot of this
enlightened centrism leads to but
needless to say trump is now jumping
into the fray he posted on his platform
truth social the other day truth
essential quote wow fox news is really
pushing the democrats and the democrat
agenda gets worse every single day
so many dems interviewed with only
softball questions then republican
counterparts get creamed
right now karl rove is unwatchable very
negative and on all the time
has a big record of losing not an easy
place to be as a republican especially
with all the pervert purchased ads
if low-rating cnn ever went conservative
they would be an absolute gold mine
and i
would help them to do so
so this is
absolutely fascinating the first
interesting element of it is
anything but complete prey at the altar
of trump
deification by fox
is considered that they've they've
turned on us they've turned on us which
of course is an absurd standard to stick
to if they want to pretend to be a news
organization which they do want to
pretend to do that's on the one hand on
the other hand
i've talked to you guys so much over the
years
of how trump doesn't really have friends
trump has people that
he sees as being useful to him
and so he'll be nice to them but as soon
as they're not useful he throws them out
and on the other and so we've said you
can be trump's best friend and the next
day if you say something negative or
even neutral about him you're you know
in a dumpster as far as trump's
concerned look at how quickly the
opposite is true as well
for years and years and years trump has
been deriding cnn as fake news enemy of
the people whatever
and all of a sudden now that it does
sort of seem like cnn might be taking a
sort of a more right-leaning approach
and trump is mad at fox trump is
immediately willing to forgive all of
the anger he's expressed against them
real anger over the last five six seven
years
and help them and by help them i assume
he means appear on the network and
whatever else
it is truly stunning and it should not
surprise us if you've been following
this i think the best possible thing is
a republican civil war
if the media civil war becomes a part of
it i'm all for it as well
we have a fascinating video of
a former attorney general william barr
basically laughing off this idea of the
blanket declassification of documents by
donald trump and saying i don't buy it
and by the way that doesn't mean you
stick the documents in a country club
which is essentially where donald trump
put them this is really interesting and
again remember william barr is a
horrible right winger william barr
stands for everything that i am against
william barr has continued to say well i
would still vote trump over a democrat
but william barr is accurately saying
this entire i put the documents in a
country club thing it doesn't make any
sense
i frankly am skeptical of this claim
that i declassified everything you know
because frankly
i think it's highly improbable
and second if in fact he sort of stood
over
scores of boxes not really knowing what
was in them and said i hereby declassify
everything in here that would be such an
abuse
uh and uh that and
show such recklessness that it's almost
worse than taking the doctor to that
point though um there's there's some
questions over the timeline uh and there
are some who fall in the camp of this
was you know looking at the
unprecedented nature of a raid of a
former president's home like this that
perhaps there was more room for the
authorities to obtain these materials
without raiding the president's home
while he was not even there do you think
this type of um this raid was was
avoidable do you think a second subpoena
for example could have been issued
well i think
whether the raid was reasonable under
the circumstances
whether there's in fact a case to be
made
and and whether or not as a matter of
prudential judgment that case should be
brought depend on two questions the i
the character of those top secret
documents and secret documents how
sensitive were they
uh and and uh
second
how raw is the evidence of deceit and
obstruction do they have really good
evidence from people who were involved
what do you think the answer to that is
i personally think for them to have
taken things to the current point they
probably have pretty good evidence but
that's speculation and until we see that
it's hard to say now let me just say
i think the driver on this from the
beginning was the it was you know loads
of classified information sitting in
mar-a-lago people say this was
unprecedented well it's also
unprecedented for a president to take
all this classified information and put
him in a country club okay
and how long is the government gonna try
to get that back you know they jawboned
for a year
they were deceived on the voluntary
actions taken
uh they then went and got a subpoena
they were deceived on that uh they feel
and the record the facts are starting to
show that they were being jerked around
yeah so listen william barr
much like john bolton is a horrible
person but he's completely right about
this all of the people saying well this
is an unprecedented action to take
against a former president
what trump did is unprecedented and when
your inputs are unprecedented your
outputs and your consequences and your
outcomes are also going to be
unprecedented logically speaking but
this entire
you can't just throw the documents in a
country club is absolutely spot on and
maybe it'll get through to some fox news
viewers now i don't know
uh whether trump is going to announce
william barr i don't barely know the guy
i don't know i met a lot of lawyers when
i was president don't really know who he
is he hasn't gotten there yet
but we may soon see that but on this
particular issue william barr is
absolutely correct
even increasingly right-wingers are
saying
this is very bad for donald trump
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay a few other
things to tell you about today uh they
the american rights maga movement is
continuing with the just assassination
talk and it started with the search
warrant at mar-a-lago
with the idea that this is the precursor
to eventually assassinating donald trump
of course completely absurd
now they're just generally going into
the assassination of people
but the blame is being placed on the
biden administration and that's how i
mean when your brain rots like this
it's how you end up with steve bannon
telling marjorie taylor green during an
interview on real america's voice war
room
something like that
um steve bannon telling marjorie taylor
green
the biden administration is trying to
assassinate people
maybe the same people that have been
swatting me or apparently you got
swatted last night and i heard it i
heard it was a pretty big deal this is
who they are this matches up with
exactly what joe biden showed us last
night
and so you know the real question is are
any of us
the bethesda bethesda speech the
scranton speech what jean prier said at
the thing about extremism if you don't
believe in in their
rule that you're an extremist and what
he said uh it's all of a peace they're
trying to have people their political
opponents assassinated death by cop
now there's a couple different things
here
the swattings
the idea i guess that bannon is saying
is
when someone gets swatted which is what
happened to marjorie taylor greene the
idea is someone calls the police and
says
oh i'm being held at marjory taylor
green's house the idea vaguely
extrapolated out fully would be the swat
team shows up and shoots marjorie taylor
green dead thinking that marjorie taylor
green is holding somebody hostage or
something that would be sort of the idea
now
the swatters are not the biden
administration and so the idea that the
biden administration wants to have their
political opponents assassinated seems
pretty wacky to extrapolate from the
facts but if you zoom out a little bit
what is happening here and their fury at
these speeches joe biden's various
speeches
is that the people who are against
democracy that's them that's steve
bannon marjorie taylor green when you
say trump really one and should be the
president that's factually incorrect and
it is a statement against democracy
democracy would be the person who won
gets to be the president the people who
are against democracy are furious
that biden called out
people who are against democracy
that's fundamentally what's going on
here the people who have laughed and
nodded along for years as trump said
lock that person up and lock this person
up and i really won the election and we
should we should um give the death
penalty for drug dealers and make me the
president even though i didn't win
now they are saying joe biden is being
really mean
and so
sadly this entire assassination thing
as they seem to be getting closer and
closer to rioting again right because
listen if trump's indicted they're going
to riot
they are making more and more claims
that the left is actually trying to kill
people so there's like three or four
different layers to this thing and of
course when we think about stochastic
terrorism in this country
it is perpetrated by the right almost
exclusively remember stochastic
terrorism is
you have an audience
and you go this is just an example you
go on every night and you go
they've got to do something about these
mexican immigrants someone's got to do
something about them
and if there's a
0.001 percent chance that someone in the
audience is going to take you literally
if there's a thousand people in your
audience it probably won't happen
if there's 10 000 people in your
audience it probably won't happen
if you've got a million or two million
people in your audience and there's that
0.000 you know whatever percent chance
and you keep saying every night
we've someone's got to take care of
these people whoever
now
it becomes statistically greater than 50
that someone in your audience is going
to go and do it and there's rarely if
ever legal liability for the stochastic
terrorists but that's been the mo of the
american right now
for a very very long time and we started
seeing this with glenn beck and others
during the obama era
i would argue even the bush era quite
frankly i'm trying to think back exactly
now
but
there's that and then there's the
projection of course
they are getting close to another riot
mark my words there will be violence
from these people if trump is indicted
which would be a completely legal
process
with all of the appropriate
legal eyes dotted and t's crossed
um and they are now talking about oh
it's the left that is about to be
violent again uh-uh not gonna happen
it's going to be these people once again
there is a bizarre new interview i have
never seen anything like this
with infowars conspiracy theorist alex
jones this is the first interview that
i'm aware of that alex jones has given
since the nearly 50 million dollar
verdict remember that the attorney for
the plaintiffs in the sandy hook
defamation case against alex jones mark
bankston joined me a couple weeks ago
we talked about a bunch of different
aspects of the trial
alex jones has now given an interview to
andrew callahan from channel 5.
it almost seems like an act so i mean
this is the way that i would say it this
is either
an act or very serious mental illness by
alex jones i don't know which one
maybe you can figure it out but he seems
very ill to me
saying he killed the victims of sandy
hook do you feel responsible for what
happened to the sandy hook families yes
i killed the children
but beyond that no i mean i went in that
school i pulled a gun out and i shot
every one of them myself i mean i
i'm i'm guilty it's true no but i don't
know let's just
do i feel responsible that someone
on on that played
video games on a bunch of drugs went and
killed a bunch of kids and then the
internet questioned it and i covered
that no i don't feel responsible and i
don't apologize anymore i'm done
i don't apologize i killed the kids
was there a definition no i killed him
i killed him he didn't kill him no i did
no you didn't no everybody said no no i
killed him
i killed him now listen if i all of a
sudden had to come up with 49.3 million
i'd probably be stressed out worse than
this but he seems very very ill i
already admit it i did it i killed him
i'm the bad guy i'm the devil you're
ready for the first amendment maybe one
other topic i don't think i killed him
first amendment killed him second get
rid of the second amendment get rid of
the first amendment they're bad they
killed the kids too george washington
killed him jesus killed him the whole we
should rename the whole planet sandy
hook everything it should be holidays we
should bow five times a day to new haven
connecticut for the kids that died every
american's to blame every gun owner is a
blame i'm to blame we are all guilty to
bloomberg and soros turn our guns in
turn our guns in i know i get it i
killed them i killed them i killed them
i i know i killed them
so i'm done talking about it
i killed them okay
can we talk about the trial at all
there's nothing to talk about let me
tell you i don't know if i can do this
interview right now
all right and then he then he walks off
so listen is that an act i don't know it
seems like he's pretty ill is my
instinct and it's also understandable if
you just had a 50 million dollar uh
judgment against you and there are more
cases and more trials to come and more
definitely i mean
to some degree i would expect that he
wouldn't be doing well
but it really is a mishmash of a lot of
different things and as attorney mark
bankston told us when i interviewed him
there are many more plaintiffs and many
more defamation cases coming so i don't
know whether this is going to be
really the end for alex jones in
infowars i mean remember when he was
kicked off of youtube etc
we were told that will be the end
but then he fundraised off of it
and then they keep making money
and they keep going
so
i don't know if and what the end is
actually going to be but in the
immediate i would be curious to hear
from you
what we just
saw do you believe that that is an act
do you believe it is real and mental
illness
or do you believe
something else i guess that it's real
and normal
given the circumstances i don't know let
me know your thoughts and we'll follow
up
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192
david p
last week we talked about hispanic and
latino and a caller called in
and is very confused about some
different terms including a third term
which is spanish
now i have a lot to say about this one
but let's first play the voicemail and
then we will discuss
yeah david i was just watching your show
on the white hispanic
progressives or whatever are the worst
i'd like to point out that there is no
country
named hispaniol
um
i've known quite a few spanish folk in
my day and i don't like the word
hispanic
because if you just break it down it's
his panic
and it's very racist
i never use it the term spanish would be
more correct it really wouldn't actually
that'll explain why in a moment because
you know there's lots of people who
speak spanish they're from the spanish
country
what is a there there's only one spanish
country in that spain okay so this is
where the confusion is and not to pick
on this guy a lot of people have this
confusion i'm going to address it in a
moment but
a spanish country there's only one
spanish country it's called spain
you know you call everybody who's brown
mexican that's kind of racist too
anyway so here you
are not only putting it in prayer but
repeatedly saying a word
that shouldn't even exist it was created
by white people
back in the days of extreme racism you
know um
like i say lots of spanish folk
they don't like that word
the
the guy is using spanish folk wrong
he
he's only making this worse
you know it is in just it's just two
words for us together
his
and panic
it's his panic and it's her panic and
it's just it's their panic
you know
does that even sound proper it's
almost like the word you know the n word
you know where you know it's negative
yeah it's really not right first of all
so so
oh my boy how do i even do this so first
of all
the way that the word hispanic sounds in
english is kind of irrelevant because
the same word ichbano exists in spanish
as well and it doesn't it it doesn't
mean
his or her panic so like that analysis
is
very odd
but
here's the bottom line on this
first of all
when we say hispanic
now i'm saying it his panic when we say
hispanic we're talking about
a spanish-speaking person
usually of latin american descent okay
now there are people like this guy who
will say what you mean is spanish these
are spanish speak people like spanish
people from mexico and spanish people
from chile but that would be wrong
the only spanish people are the people
of spain
there is one spanish country and it's
called spain if you're from spain you're
spanish
if you're from mexico you're mexican if
you're from argentina you're argentinian
if you're from chile you're chilean so
the spanish thing is neither here nor
there and this is a big source of
confusion where i've met people who go
oh
you're you're spanish
no i'm argentinian in argentina they
speak spanish i've also had people say
when i say oh i'm from argentina they go
oh i didn't know you were mexican
i'm not
i'm from argentina different country
but
the third part of this is
the racist origin of the term hispanic
now there is a lot of scholarship on
this
i can tell you personally as someone who
is not spanish i'm not from spain
but i consider myself both hispanic and
latino
either word is fine
and my belief is that it is a correct
word to describe me in the united states
based on the senses i'm considered
hispanic
and i am also of latino origin latin
american descent whatever but spanish is
very wrong i'm definitely not spanish so
i hope that that clarified an altogether
confusing situation
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad we will
talk about the mass stabbing in canada
which is being used by a lot of people
for political reasons we will talk about
a nirvana lawsuit over the album cover
to their 1991 and never mind album very
interesting lawsuit
and we will talk about ron desantis's
voter fraud hunt which has completely
backfired sign up at joinpackman.com
and if you want to take advantage of an
ungodly membership discount
we will be emailing everyone on our
newsletter list on 9 19 about a 19
themed membership special
you need only get on my mailing list by
signing up at davidpakman.com sign up
there and then on the morning of 9 19
you will get a beautiful email telling
you how to sign up i will either see you
on the bonus show today or back here
tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below